باختصار الحقيقه ال همم
المنطلق الفلسفي والفكري للحركات همم
الاسلام ما يسمى بحركات الاسلام السياسي
انه اسميها حركات التفسير السياسي للاسلام
هي بدات منذ وقت مبكر بدات على يد رجلين
احدهما في المشرق همم
العراء في المشرق الاسلامي همم في الهند
على يد سيد احمد خان واا ثم التلميذ محمد
اقبال في همم منطقتنا نشا على يد جمال
الدين الافغاني اا كانت الفكره هي تبني
التفسير المصلحي همم للدين وهمم كان ذلك
في همم نهايه او بدايه سقوط السلطنه همم
العثمانيه همم طرحت فكره انشاء الجامعه
الاسلاميه التي طرحها جمال الدين الافغاني
همم في الهند ايضا همم سيد احمد خان كان
له طرح مماثل همم نظرا لاحتك بالفلسفات
الاوروبيه وكذا فخلط بين ما يريده اصلاحا
وبين هذه النظريه بقي هذا الفكر همم مجرد
بين النخل
وفي عام همم
1928 همم
حرك هذا
الامر ونفخ فيه الروح حسن البنا في مصر
وكذلك في بشكل شبه متزامن ابو الاعلى
الموجود في القاره الهنديه فهنا نشات ال
ال ال الحركات همم الاسلاميه همم التي
تتبنى التفسير السياسي للاسلام تفسير
السياسي يعني همم ان همم الهدف همم صلاحيه
الغايه في الاسلام هي اقامه الحكم هنا
وهنا مكمل همم الخطوره
وبالتالي همم هذا مخالفه لانهاج الرباني
وهو تعبير الناس اللي رب العالمين الاصل
في ذلك العباده يعني اللي همم وياتي
التمكين والحكومه لذلك
اشياء تابعه حسب الهمم لذلك الله سبحانه
وتعالى يقول الذين امكنهم في الارض همم
فقال هنا في اشتراط
فليس التمكين ضروره المهم هو همم عباده
الله سبحانه وتعالى وايصال هذا الدين الى
الناس هؤلاء لا همم يعني جعلوا السياسه
اصل وان الوصول الحكم وما يسميه المودود
وتبعه سيد قطب همم غيره بالانقلاب همم
سياسي للوصول الى سده الحكم ثم التغيير
طبعا نتج ان هذا الفكر وهذه الفلسفه تكفير
المجتمعات الاسلاميه وهمم
تكفير الحكومات والحكام وعدم شر رايتهم
والخروج عليهم